The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So today's topic
is to talk about Z-transforms.
But before I start,
I want to mention
that we've already covered
a great deal of material.
Here, I've made a map just
of things we've done in DT,
and there's a fair
number of entries.
More importantly, there's a
fair number of connections
between those entries.
And if you're thinking
about systems,
you should be able
to think about,
what do each one of
those arrows stand for?
The reason that's
important is that we
like to have multiple
representations for the system
so that we're always able
to choose the one that
lets us work the most simply.
But sometimes that involves
moving between the squares.
So the way the problem
was posed to you
may not be the simplest
way to solve it,
and that involves, then, going
across one of those arrows.
So for example, we
know that there's
a simple relationship between
block diagrams and system
functionals.
All you need to do
is think about delays
as being the right
shift operator.
That's a way of thinking about
the system functional is just
a formula picture of
the block diagram.
Similarly, we can think about
moving between the block
diagram and the
difference equation
by thinking about delay
being a shift of the index.
So you should be able to think
of ways of thinking about all
of the transformations
between the boxes.
Over here, we thought
about system functionals.
How do you think about a system
as a sequence of operations
that you do to a signal?
We also thought about
system functions,
and there's a very simple
relationship between those.
You think about the operator
expression that involves
Rs and replace each R with 1/z.
OK, that was all a big
set up, because now I
want to ask a question.
Using your vast knowledge of how
all these things interrelate,
what's the relationship
between the system functional,
a function of R, and the
unit sample response?
As usual, I'd like you to talk
to your neighbor to figure this
out, and as usual, you won't
do that unless I tell you
to do something trivial first.
So look toward your
neighbor, say, "Hi."
Wonderful, good.
Now, figure out this problem.
OK, how many of you--
I want a show of hands.
How many of you know a way of
getting between those boxes?
Raise your hand.
How many of you are
sitting beside somebody
who knows the way to
get between those boxes?
No.
OK, that didn't work either.
OK, can somebody tell me, if I
told you a system functional,
say I told you that one,
how would I figure out
the unit sample response
from the system function--
functional?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Don't you take
the inverse Laplace of it?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Inverse Laplace.
OK, that's kind of
right, but not quite.
So usually, the
answer to the question
is either the slide before
this one or the slide
after this one.
So that doesn't quite fit this.
The slide before this one said
something about Z-transforms.
Can somebody think
of a way, if I
told you the system
functional is this thing,
how would you derive the
unit sample response?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You could convert
it into a difference equation
and then just work
it out manually.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Convert it
into a difference equation.
That would work.
So what you could do is go
from this box to that box.
Then, if you had
this box how would
you get the unit
sample response?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] delta.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Put a
delta into the difference.
Think about the difference
equation being a system.
Put a delta in and
see what comes out.
Exactly.
Can somebody think
of a more direct way
that doesn't skirt through
the difference equation?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Multiply the system
functional by a delta function.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Multiply the
I'm not quite sure
what that means,
but I'm willing to try anything.
1 over 1 minus R
minus R squared.
Multiply that times
a delta function.
What do I do next?
OK, as I said, the
answer to the question
is usually something
that we just did
or something we're
just about to do.
Where did we spend the
last three weeks doing?
No, it's not three weeks.
It's only a week, but,
you know, I exaggerate.
What have we been doing?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: We could use
long division [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: One way
would be use long division.
How would that work?
If we did 1/1--
maybe I'd better use a
bigger blackboard space--
if I tried to do 1 over 1 minus
R minus R squared, if I tried
to think about that
by long division,
I would do 1 minus R
minus R squared into 1.
How would that work?
Well, I'd go 1--
I'd go 1 goes into 1 once.
I get 1 minus R minus R squared.
This minus this gives
me R plus R squared.
This goes into this plus
R. That gives me whatever.
Having done it in the
solitude of my own breakfast
this morning, here's an
answer that I got there.
So if I perform long
division on the functional,
I get this kind of an answer.
The question was,
how do I relate
the functional to the
unit sample response?
How do I-- how do I relate this
to the unit sample response?
AUDIENCE: The
coefficient [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: The
coefficients [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: The
coefficients of this expression
are the unit sample response.
OK?
So there's a very
straightforward way.
If I tell you the
system functional,
if I tell you this
representation,
there's a very simple way
that we've thought about
by which you can
automatically calculate what
is the unit sample response?
OK?
In fact, it's so simple that
we can write a formula for it.
Think about the unit sample
response being h of n.
Associate the h 0
term with a constant,
the h 1 term with an R, with
the h 2 term with an R squared.
Add them all together,
that's the answer.
So the way you get between these
representations is very simple.
Here's the unit sample response,
here's the system functional,
and here's an equation
that relates the two
representations.
That all completely clear?
Simple.
Yes, hi.
Everything clear?
Questions, comments?
OK, a follow-up question.
So here's a relationship between
these two representations.
How about a relationship between
these two representations?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Same relationship.
Just use one of
the place markers.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Precisely.
So it's really-- so we got
this one in the previous step.
R is just 1/z, so we get this.
So we get a relationship
that looks like that.
OK, that relationship is the
basis of today's lecture.
We call that relationship--
so that relationship represents
a mathematical relationship
between a function of
z and a function of n,
and we call that
relationship the Z-transform.
So that's the topic for today.
We're going to think about
systems, not as an operator,
but as a mathematical
function, h of z.
So the first thing to realize
is that this transform then,
this thing that we're going
to be worried about today
is a map between a
discrete function
and a continuous function of z.
And even though
it's been motivated,
I motivated it by
thinking about how
it would relate to a
system, that relationship
between a function of
z and a function of n
is something that you could do
on any discrete time signal.
So in fact, if you
have any signal x of n,
we can think about
the Z-transform of it
by simply thinking about what
that equation is telling us.
How does it map from a function
of n to a function of z?
I've written it in a little--
in a way that you might
not have anticipated.
You might have thought I
would have started at 0.
That's just because
we're going to do what's
called the bilateral transform.
There are many kinds
of Z-transforms.
We're going to do
this particular one.
Other classes that
you might take
may use something
called a unilateral.
If you're not
taking such a class,
there's no good reason
for you to know that.
If you are taking such a
class, we're doing bilateral.
That just means
two-sided, and we'll
see by the end of the hour how
that makes some things simpler.
The big picture is
identical whether you
do unilateral or bilateral,
but there are differences.
OK.
Simple Z-transforms.
What's the Z-transform
of the simplest
signal that we can imagine?
Simplest signal
that we can imagine
is the unit sample signal.
It's 0 everywhere
except n equals 0.
At n equals 0, it's the simplest
possible non-zero answer,
which is 1.
What's the Z-transform?
Well, that's trivial.
You stick it in the formula.
The only non-zero
answer is at n equals 0.
Stick in n equals 0, and
we get that the answer
is the Z-transform is 1.
What could be easier?
Good.
Simple signal in time, simple
signal in the Z-transform.
What's the Z-transform for a
delayed unit sample signal?
What happens if the only
place that it's not 0
is shifted to n equals 1?
Not a big deal.
Again, there's a
single non-zero answer,
it's just that it's
now at n equals 1.
So this answer is
z to the minus 1.
We took a signal that
was a function of n,
and we represent it
by a Z-transform,
which is a function of z.
Delta of n is 1.
Delta of n minus 1
is z to the minus 1.
OK, with that vast
knowledge of Z-transforms,
figure out the Z-transform for
a slightly more complicated
sequence of the
type-- of the type
that we saw when we
were looking at systems.
What if the signal that
we're interested in
is 7/8 to the n, u of n,
where I'm using the u of n
just to cut off the negative
parts of 7/8 to the n.
So find the
Z-transform, and find
if it looks like one
of those four answers
or none, which is number five.
So what answer best represents
the Z-transform of the signal
x?
Raise your hand, number
one through five.
It's a participatory sport.
Good 97% correct, I think.
So OK.
Everybody says two.
How do you get two?
What do you do?
Plug in the formula, right?
It's a very simple-minded thing.
If you were to think
about this signal
and think about the
definition of the Z-transform,
just substitute this particular
signal, 7/8 to the n, u of n,
in where there would
have been the x of n
and try to close the sum, right?
It's a geometric sequence.
We've had lots of experience
with geometric sequences.
It was in the
homework, and so we all
know that the answer to
summing a geometric--
a one-sided geometric sequence
is something of the form
1 over 1 minus a.
OK, easy, right?
So the idea, then,
is that we understand
a general rule by which we
can map a function of time
into a function of z.
So the function of time has
to make sense everywhere.
That's-- we want
that to be true.
We want to know what was
the system's unit sample
response, for example, or what
was the input to the system,
or whatever.
We want to know that at
all possible values of n.
How about the other case?
Does it make sense?
Is x of z makes sense for
all possible values of z?
And since I ask the
question, the answer is no.
Yes, of course.
I wouldn't have
asked the question
if the answer were yes, right?
So by the theory
of lecturers, you
can tell the answer
has to have been no.
So the question is, what
values of z don't make sense?
Shout.
AUDIENCE: The summation
of the [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: The
summation has to converge,
so it's only going to be defined
if this sum, which happens
to be an infinite sum and
therefore may not converge,
it's going to have to be the
case that that infinite sum
does converge.
Otherwise, it won't make
sense to talk about it.
So then the question
is, for what values of z
will that converge?
And again, we know
from our experience
with geometric sequences that
the base of the geometric, a,
when we did homework one,
the base of the geometric
has to have what?
What's the property
of the base of the--
the geometric
that'll make it work?
So if I want to sum some
series of the form n equals 0
to infinity a to the
n, what's the values--
what's the limitation
on a that makes it work?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: OK,
you're not saying it
loud enough or clearly enough,
or I'm too dense or something.
AUDIENCE: Abs less than 1?
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
we need something--
we need abs less than 1, right.
So we do the same thing here.
We're going to have to have
that the geometric base, 7/8 1
over z has to be less-- has
to have a magnitude that
is less than 1.
And if we torture our minds
with inequalities and magnitude
signs, that says that
the magnitude of z
has to be bigger than 7/8.
OK?
The important idea is
that when we characterize
the Z-transform, we
should be expecting
it to work for all values
of n, but not necessarily
all values of z.
So we have to be
cognizant of that.
We have to know which values
of z are you talking about.
We call that idea the
region of convergence.
We say the Z-transform converged
for all z inside the region
of convergence.
So when you specify
a Z-transform,
generally, you have to tell me
not just some functional form,
but you also have
to tell me what
was the region for which that
functional form converged.
So in general, you have to tell
me the region of convergence.
In this particular
case, you have
to tell me that
you should restrict
your attention to values
of z whose magnitude is
bigger than 7/8.
OK?
OK, that's completely the whole
definition of Z-transforms.
We're done from a point of
view of mathematics, right?
So all we need to know is that
the Z-transform of a signal
is some sum of the signal z to
the minus n, and we're done.
We need to know about the
region of convergence,
but mathematically, we've
completely specified
the problem at this point.
To make it useful,
however, what we need to do
is investigate properties
of that transformation.
If the transformation were
not easy to manipulate,
we wouldn't bother with it.
So we want to know what's easy
to do with the Z-transform
and what's not easy to
do with the Z-transform.
When something's easy to do with
the Z-transform, we'll use it.
When things are easier
to do some other way,
we use the other way.
That's the game plan.
So there's a number of
properties of the Z-transform
that make it easy or
hard to do things.
So we'll talk about
the easy ones.
The most fundamental
one is linearity.
Basically, this entire subject
is about linear things.
If it's not linear, largely,
we don't talk about it.
The reason is we have such
powerful tools for thinking
about things that are linear.
This is one of them.
If-- so we say that
the Z-transform is
a linear operator,
and all that means
is if you apply the Z-transform
to the sum of two things,
you get the sum
of the things out.
It's a little more
complicated than that.
If I were being a
little more careful--
in fact, I didn't quite say
a complete definition here.
This is certainly true, but
there are additional things
that are also true.
We say that the
Z-transform is linear
because if we knew the
z-transform for X 1,
that includes a functional form
and a region of convergence,
and if we knew the
Z-transform for X 2,
again, a functional form
and a region of convergence,
then by the linearity
of the operator,
we can figure out just from
the two Z-transforms, what
is the Z-transform of the sum.
And that's trivial to see.
It's easy to see why it
ought to be that way.
Just look at--
let's think about y,
which is the signal,
which is the sum.
By the definition
of Z-transform,
the Z-transform of the
sum is that formula.
Y, by definition, is that thing.
Z commutes-- distributes
over addition,
and the sum separates.
So we can always
reduce this to this,
at least when the case that z is
in both regions of convergence.
Though later in
the course, we'll
see that that's a little
overly restrictive.
Sometimes it works for more
zs than in the intersection.
But it's guaranteed to
work in the intersection,
because I know that I can do
this sum if z is in ROC 1.
I know I can do this
sum if z is in ROC 2.
So I know I can do both of them
if it's in the intersection.
We'll see a little
later that sometimes you
can do it even when it's
not in the intersection.
But for the time being,
we know you can do it
if it's in the intersection.
So because of linearity, we know
that the Z-transform of a sum
is the sum of the Z-transforms.
I didn't realize when
I made this slide,
linearity implies
more than that.
I could have done
a weighted sum.
I could have said if X 1 goes
to X1 and X 2 goes to X 2,
then alpha 1, X 1
plus alpha 2, X 2
goes to alpha 1, X
1 plus alpha 2, X 2.
I should have put
that in the slide,
and it just didn't occur to me.
So the idea of linearity
is slightly more powerful
than the example
that I gave here.
But again, linearity is the
most fundamental property
of Z-transforms.
If the Z-transform
weren't linear,
we wouldn't bother with it.
But it is, so we do.
Another important property
is the delay property.
Think about what we do
with discrete signals.
We put them through
discrete systems.
Discrete systems of the
type we've looked at so far
have adders, delays, gains.
Delays.
If the Z-transform
couldn't handle delays,
again, we wouldn't do it, right?
Delays are so
fundamental to the way
we think about discrete
systems that it
must be the case that
Z-transforms deal
with delays well, and they do.
We've already seen two examples.
The first example I did
was the unit sample signal
has a transform of 1, and the
delayed unit sample's signal
has transform of
z to the minus 1.
So there's a simple
relationship--
if I knew the first, how
I could find the second.
More generally, if I had
a signal X and I knew its
transform X, then I could
readily compute the transform
of the shifted version just from
the transform of the unshifted
version, and that's-- you
can see how that would work
mathematically.
Let's call the
shifted version Y,
then the transform of
the shifted version
is given by this expression.
By the definition
of shift, y of n
is the same as x of n minus 1.
And now all we need to
do is massage the math
so it ends up looking like the
definition of a Z-transform.
So the way to do that would be
to substitute m for n minus 1.
We get something that looks
more like a Z-transform.
And if we bring this
minus 1 out front,
it looks exactly like a
Z-transform pre-multiplied by z
to the minus 1.
So the delay theorem
just says if I already
know the Z-transform
of a signal,
then to find the Z-transform
of the delayed version
of that signal, simply multiply
the original Z-transform by z
to the minus 1.
OK?
So so far, I've talked
about two properties
of Z-transforms, linearity
and the delay property.
And in combination, they
let me do a lot of stuff
with discrete systems.
So think, for
example, of a system,
a discrete system
that can be described
by a linear difference equation
with constant coefficients.
If you can describe
a system that way,
then you can write the
relationship between the input
signal X and the output signal
Y that looks like a difference
equation.
Then, if you take into
account that the Z-transform
is both linear and has a simple
representation for delays,
I can take the Z-transform
of that difference equation
and get a new expression.
So the difference equation
represents an equality
between two sums of
time domain signals.
Taking the Z-transform
of that equality
tells me some
equivalent relationship
of the Z-transforms.
So if I-- so I think about the
left-hand side by linearity,
I can find the
Z-transform of this sum
by finding the sum
of the Z-transforms.
And so this one's easy, right?
The Z-transform of y of n
is, by assumption, y of z.
By linearity, the part
I didn't show you,
if I pre-multiply
by b nought, it's
pre-multiplied by b nought.
Because it's linear, I can
just add the next term to it.
The next term looks a lot
like the previous term
except that it's shifted,
but shift is easy.
You just put z to
the minus 1 in front.
So this term just becomes
b one, z to the minus 1.
This just becomes b
2, z to the minus 2,
and the whole thing factors.
Same sort of thing
happens on the X side,
and you end up with a
very simple statement.
The Z-transform of a system
that can be represented
by a difference equation
with constant coefficients is
the ratio of two polynomials
in z to the minus 1--
this is a polynomial
in z to the minus 1.
Or if I multiply top and
bottom by z to the k,
I can make it look like a
ratio of polynomials in z.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why is it y to
the x on the b 0 [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Why is it y the x?
Because of my poor typography.
Thank you very much.
That's completely wrong.
OK, so I'll try to remember
that when I get to my office
and change it before
I post it on the web.
Thank you.
So this is y of z, this
is y of z, this is y of z.
That is-- and you can see I
used [? e-max, ?] so I copied
the formula and I got the
single error to turn into two.
It's always very good when
you can do that, right?
Something like that.
OK, so the point
then is that simply
by knowing that the Z-transform
is linear and has a delay
property, it results in
a very simple statement
about the Z-transform for a
system that can be represented
by such a difference equation.
OK.
Now we use a little bit of
knowledge about polynomials.
We use the idea that
the fundamental theorem
in algebra--
anybody have any
idea what that is?
Nah.
Fundamental theorem
of algebra, what?
AUDIENCE: That was
a long time ago.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Long time ago.
If it was long for you, think
about when it was for me.
[LAUGHTER]
No, you can't think that way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are we [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Wonderful.
Everybody hear that?
Because I can't repeat it.
But everybody hear that?
An nth order
polynomial has n roots.
Roughly speaking.
I'm not a mathematician, right?
I'm an engineer.
Right?
An nth order
polynomial has n roots.
OK, and then the factor theorem.
Surprisingly enough, that
says you can factor things.
So the idea then is that if I
can represent the Z-transform
as a ratio of polynomials and
z, there's a factored form.
And that's the basis
of a decomposition
that we will make
extensive use of.
You've already
seen, extensively,
the roots of the denominator.
They're the poles.
We will similarly define,
because of this manipulation,
the roots of the numerator.
They're the zeros.
OK?
So-- and it's pretty easy
to think through, then,
how there is a relationship--
it's all about
relationships, right?
When I introduce
something, I want
to think about how
the thing I just said
relates to everything
else I've ever said.
There's a simple relationship
between poles and regions
of convergence.
Turns out the regions
of convergence
are always going to be circles.
That has-- circles
in the z plane.
That has to do with
things like convergence
of geometric sequences.
If I build my system out of
adders and delays and gains,
then I have that
complex set of reasoning
that gives rise to the idea
that I have polynomials.
That's going to be-- that's
going to give rise to,
if you think about
poles, partial fractions,
each of those is going
to have some kind
of a characteristic response.
It's going to be a
geometric sequence.
Each of those is going to have
a convergence property that
has something to do with
a circle in the z plane.
Each of those circles is
going to be bounded by a pole.
So the upshot of
all that stuff is
there's a relationship
between poles
and regions of convergence.
Regions of
convergence are always
going to be circles
in the z plane,
and they're always going
to be bounded by a pole.
And we've seen an
example of that already.
If we had a geometric
sequence that
was defined only to the
right of n equals 0--
if it is non-zero, only
at n equals 0 or bigger--
then we get convergence
inside some region defined
by when the base has an absolute
value that's less than 1.
That's a circle in the z plane.
And the pole, which is
alpha, turns into the edge
of that circle of convergence.
So the regions of convergence
for these kinds of systems
will always be circles in
the z plane, always bounded
by a pole.
OK, enough of my talking.
What DC-- what DT signal has
the following Z-transform?
I want to know a DT signal
that has transform of the form
z over z minus 7/8 with
a region of convergence
inside absolute value
of z equals 7/8.
So what's the DT signal
that has that Z-transform?
AUDIENCE: It would
be Y to the n is
equal to x to the n plus
7/8y to the n minus 1?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Sounded
like a difference equation.
Say it again.
AUDIENCE: Oh yeah.
Isn't that what
you're looking for?
DENNIS FREEMAN: No.
I wanted the signal.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So I
want to think about--
this is a little confusing.
I apologize if I didn't
say this clearly.
We motivated the
idea of Z-transform
by looking at systems, but
the result, the Z-transform's
just a relationship.
It's a map between a function
of n and a function of z.
So we can do that
for every signal.
So if I tell you
the function of z,
you can figure out
the function of n.
The question here is
intended-- what I intended was,
what's the function
of n that corresponds
to that function of z?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: 7/8
to the n, u of n.
That sounds like
something we did before.
7/8 to the n, u of n.
That sounds like something
we did before, actually.
Yes, no?
Something we did before
is a good thing, right?
That's one of the
general rules, right?
When I ask a question,
look at what we did before.
That's a good rule.
Is that the same
Z-transform we did before?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yes, yes.
The region of convergence that
we did before was outside 7/8,
and the region of convergence
I asked for in this problem
is inside 7/8 So what's
the effect of switching
the region of convergence?
What happens if I switch
AUDIENCE: Does z change?
Does the value of z change?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Z. It's hard
to talk about the value of z,
right?
Z.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Excuse me.
So z is defined--
the Z-transform is
defined this way.
So I want to say that h of z
is always z over z minus 7/8.
What happens if I say
the region switched?
Well, it says something
about convergence.
What's convergence
have to do with?
Convergence has to do with,
well, I'm thinking about h
of z is some sum over n of
h of n, z to the minus n.
So convergent has to do
with which ones of those ns
can be in the sum, because
some of these terms, z
to the minus n, when
I switch the region,
I consider a
different family of z.
In the first one, that sum had
to converge outside the circle.
And in the question of interest
now, it has to converge inside.
So it's a different
set of zs for which
the sum has to converge.
There's a way you
can think about that.
Think about that sum--
think about exploding that sum.
In general, we're going
to go from minus infinity
to infinity, so explode that.
So we get a whole
bunch of stuff.
Then we get up to h
of minus 2, z squared.
Then we have h of minus 1, z.
Then we have h of 0, z
to the 0, which is 1.
Then we have h of
1, z to the minus 1.
Then we have h of 2, z to
the minus 2, et cetera.
Right?
That's what the Z-transform
always looks like.
Which of those terms
are the most convergent
when I have a z with
a large magnitude?
So I'm thinking about
the n equals minus 2,
n equals minus 1, n equals 0.
I'm thinking about
all the terms and Ys.
Which of those terms
is the most convergent
if z has a large magnitude?
AUDIENCE: I think it
would be z of negative n.
Like, any negative.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So they get
increasingly convergent as I
go to the right.
If I have z with
a big magnitude,
each term is getting
increasingly convergent
as I go to the right.
That means that these
numbers h 0, h 1, h 2, h 3,
they can keep being
some finite number.
They don't need to be 0.
And it will increasingly
come closer to 0
as I keep going to the right.
The implication of
that is something
that's very important.
So the implication of that is
that a right-sided signal--
signal, not single-- has a--
maps to an outside region.
If I want the sum to get
increasingly convergent
for large values of
z, outside regions--
outside regions have
to take all the values,
no matter how big they get.
OK, I want things
to be on the right.
I don't want things
to be on the left.
Things on the left become
decreasingly convergent.
And a corollary of
that, left-sided signals
map to inside regions.
So in fact, it's not a fluke
that this right-handed signal
mapped to this outside region.
That's where the convergence
for things to the right
are the best.
OK.
Now I've just told you
everything you need to know.
What's it going
to-- what do I need
to have happen if I want it to
converge to the inside region?
Flip the signal.
More or less, I want
it to go to the left.
I don't want it to
go to the right.
So the way I can
think about that
is by thinking about
the functional form
is the same for the inside
and the outside region.
That means they have the
same difference equation,
because you can find
the difference equation
from the functional form.
But the way I want
to think about it
is propagating the signal
that came in to the right
or to the left.
So rather then iterating
forward in time,
which is what we did before,
one way I can think about it is,
let's iterate backwards in time.
Rather than solving for y of
n plus 1 in terms of y of n,
solve instead for y of n
in terms of y of n plus 1.
Run it backwards.
Difference equation
doesn't care.
If the difference
equation doesn't care,
the functional form
will be the same.
So run the difference
equation backwards.
So if you think about doing
that, rest starts to say,
the system starts--
starts means future times,
OK, because we're flipped.
So the signal starts at 0.
That means it starts--
that means at large values
of n, the signal y is 0.
So I fill in this
table with a bunch
of zeros for big values of n.
So n's decreasing this way.
I'm working from toward--
0 toward the left.
So I assume that
I start at rest.
That means the output is
0 for times on the right.
I want to find the unit sample
response, so x is 1 only at n
equals 0.
And now I just
compute each entry
by sticking it into the
difference equation.
And so I've done that.
So you stick these values
into the difference equation,
and that lets you
compute y of minus 1.
So substitute y of minus 1.
Y of minus 1, it depends
on y of 0 and x of 0.
Similarly for all
the entries, and then
I can make a plot of
that, and I get a function
that looks like this.
It's a geometric.
I'm not surprised by that.
The geometric is kind
of facing the wrong way.
It was 7/8 to the end.
It looked convergent.
This one looks
divergent that way,
but I'm multiplying
these h numbers, which
are blowing up that
way, by numbers
that look like z squared.
So if I make z squared small
enough, it'll still converge.
That's the idea.
OK?
By flipping the
region of convergence,
I've changed the magnitudes
of these numbers,
and I've changed which
side converges best.
I've made something that--
it's an inside region.
It was converging for z
values inside some region,
so it's become left-sided.
So the idea then is that I have
two different kinds of time
signals that are both associated
with the same functional form
of z.
They differ by the
region of convergence.
That's why when you
tell me a Z-transform,
you have to tell me the
region of convergence.
OK?
OK.
So I've given some exercises.
I'm running out of time.
The best thing to do is to think
about the exercises offline.
I could lead you
through the math.
That's never very inspirational.
So what I wanted to show you
is that there's many ways
that you can go about
expressing a complicated form
by partial fractions to get
a simpler form that can then
be inverted this way.
So that's the point
of this exercise.
So I went through in the notes,
and the notes are online.
So in the notes, I went
through three different ways
you can think of the answer,
and all of those answers
give you the same
functional form, right?
So it was an exercise
in thinking through how
you do partial fractions.
But there's one more thing
that I want to talk about,
and that is that a lot of these
problems-- one of the biggest
uses of Z-transforms is to
solve difference equations.
Z-transforms are great for that.
I've already talked about that.
With-- by using a Z-transform,
you can take a difference
equation, think about
the difference equation,
think about the input, take the
Laplace transform of everything
you get--
Laplace transform--
a Z-transform, sorry.
Slipped.
Next time it will be
Laplace transform.
Take a Z-transform.
You end up with a Z-transform,
and then the trick
is to recognize the
inverse Z-transform.
There are ways of thinking
about that as a mathematician.
Those ways are not easy,
so by and large, we
will never do this.
If you would like to do that,
I highly recommend course 18.
OK?
It is certainly something
that people in course 18
do all the time, but there
are always simpler ways
that we will do it,
and those simpler ways
derive from thinking about
properties of the z-transform.
And we'll think more about those
as we go forward in the course.
So the point of today
was to emphasize
that there are lots of
different ways of thinking
about DT systems.
You should be able to think of
all the relations between them.
And in particular,
today we talked
about this thing, a
mathematical relationship
for how you can go from
a unit sample response
to a system function.
See you next week.